encontremos la ecuación de regresión
lineal que mejor se ajusta a estos
puntos donde el ajuste minimiza el
cuadro de las distancias a cada uno de
estos puntos y después de hecho vamos a
calcular que también es este ajuste
usando la erre cuadrada quizá hagamos
eso en otro vídeo dependiendo del tiempo
recordemos la ecuación de la recta es
que igual a m x + b y ya hemos
demostrado que la pendiente de esta
recta aquella que minimiza el cuadro y
la distancia cada uno de estos puntos es
igual a la media de las x es menos la
media las x por la media la 10
todo eso dividido entre las medias de
las x al cuadrado de la media las x
cuadradas menos
media de las la media de las x elevado
al cuadrado la media y las x elevado al
cuadrado y una manera de recordar esto
es los primeros términos tenemos la
media de los términos combinados es
decir aquí tenemos la x multiplicada por
sí misma y luego sacar la media que
multiplicamos x porque y luego tomamos
la media y en los siguientes términos
tomamos primero la media aquí tenemos la
media la x por la media la ye y luego el
denominador tenemos la media de la x
elevada al cuadrado espero que esto te
ayude quizás no lo haga pero bueno si
calculamos la pendiente y luego entonces
la ordenada al origen va a ser igual a
la media de y menos el valor de m que
calculamos por la media de x y podemos
hacer esto porque sabemos que el punto x
media coma media va a estar sobre la
recta de regresión vamos a calcular la y
ya verás en el último ejemplo tuvimos
tres puntos aquí sólo tenemos cuatro
puntos pero los cálculos se complican y
puedes imaginarte lo que pasaría si
tuvieras diez puntos o veinte puntos oa
un 100 puntos tendrás que usar en este
caso una calculadora o quizá el mejor
una computadora o inclusive una hoja de
cálculo calculemos m y para esto
calculemos cada uno de los componentes
entonces la media de las x es igual a
menos 2
más menos 1 más 14 dividido entre 4
tenemos cuatro valores de x menos uno
más uno se cancelan nos queda menos dos
más cuatro que es igual a dos entre
cuatro es igual a un medio hagamos ahora
la media de las diez
tenemos aquí menos 3
aquí tenemos menos 1 acá tenemos 2 y 3
todo eso dividido entre 4 tenemos 4
puntos menos 3 y 3 se cancelan nos queda
menos uno más dos es igual a 1 entre 4
es igual a un cuarto calculemos ahora la
media de las x yes
entonces x porque y su media aquí
tenemos menos 2 por menos tres menos dos
por menos tres es igual a seis
más menos 1 x menos uno es igual a 1 más
1 por 2 es igual a 2 + 4 por 3 es igual
a 12 sobre 4 puntos que tenemos y esto
nos da 6 17 29 más 12 21 sobre 4 es
igual a 21 cuartos a ver verifiquemos 6
+ 1 729 12 21 21 4 es correcto y
finalmente necesitamos voy a hacer en
otro color la media de las x al cuadrado
la media las x cuadradas y esto es igual
menos 2 al cuadrado es 4 más menos 1 al
cuadrado es uno más uno al cuadrado es
uno más cuatro al cuadrado es 16 sobre 4
y aquí tenemos 4 26 16 22 22 sobre 4 22
sobre 4 que es igual a 11
24 26 16 22 sobre 411 vengeance y está
bien ya podemos calcular ahora la
pendiente déjame hacerlo por aquí no
mejor acá abajo quiero quiero hacerlo
donde podamos ver todo voy a hacerlo
aquí vamos a lo aquí entonces esto va a
ser igual la media de las x es la media
la psiquis y es que es igual a 21
cuartos menos
la media de la x la media de las x por
la media el asia es la media de las
equis que es un medio
- un medio por la media de las 10 que es
igual a un cuarto menos un medio por un
cuarto sobre
la media de las equis cuadradas que
tenemos aquí que son se medios menos la
media de las equis elevado al cuadrado
la media de las equis que es igual a un
medio elevado al cuadrado ya que es
igual esto voy a sacar directamente la
calculadora podría manipular hasta
acciones pero ésta no es una revisión de
suma resta multiplicación de fracciones
así es que voy a sacar directamente la
calculadora
de hecho déjame simplificar la es muy
tentador simplificar la vamos a
simplificar la por acá
déjame hacer un copiar y pegar
entonces le doy copiar pegar y voy a
ponerla por aquí para simplificarla fue
demasiado tentador simplificar y caí en
la tentación entonces esto va a ser
21 cuartos menos un medio por un cuarto
que es un octavo sobre 11 medios menos
un medio al cuadrado que es igual a un
cuarto una manera de hacer esto es
multiplicar numerador y denominador por
8 entonces multiplicamos por 8 octavos
para deshacernos de estas fracciones y
que tenemos en el numerador tenemos 21
cuartos por 8 el 21 por 2 42 menos un
octavo por 8 tenemos por supuesto que
distribuir los ochos esto va a ser
entonces menos 1 entre 11 medios por 8
es 11 x 4 que es igual a 44 menos un
cuarto por 8 que es igual a 2 y aquí que
tenemos arriba el numerador tenemos 42
menos 141 entre 44 menos 2 es 42
entonces la pendiente es 41 42 abós es
una pendiente ligeramente menor a 1 si
hubieran sido 42 42 ambos hubiera sido
exactamente 1 por lo cual nuestra
pendiente regresión es ligera
de menor a 1 ahora la ordenada al origen
de la recta de regresión va a ser igual
b es igual a la media de las 10 que es
igual a un cuarto menos
la pendiente que acabamos de calcular
que es 41 42 a vos por la media de las x
la media de las equis que la tenemos
aquí que es igual a un medio esto va a
ser igual
a un cuarto menos 41 42 a 2.41 entre 84
y voy a hacer esta esta resta voy a
sacar aquí como un denominador común
denominador de 484 es 84 ahora aquí voy
a tomar un cuarto de 84 un cuarto de 84
es 21 es correcto esto si 21 84 a vos
equivale a un cuarto menos 41 entre 84
21 menos 41 es menos 20 sobre 84 y aquí
aún puedo simplificar como cuarta arriba
es menos 540 - 20 es igual o menos 5 y 4
84 es 21 entonces la ecuación de la
recta de regresión es igual
a 41 sobre 42 x x menos 5 sobre 21 y 5
sobre 21 es ligeramente menor a un
cuarto 5 sobre 20 es un cuarto hicimos
ligeramente mayor el denominador
entonces 5 sobre 21 ligeramente menor un
cuarto nuestra orden al origen va a
estar por aquí y al ser negativa va a
ser ligeramente mayor a menos 14 vamos a
tener una pendiente ligeramente menor a
1 se verá algo así si fuera la pendiente
igual a 1 pero es un poquito menos
inclinada se vería así la recta si fuera
capaz de hacer una línea perfectamente
recta pero la recta de regresión se va a
ver aproximadamente así hasta aquí voy a
dejar este vídeo en el próximo vídeo
vamos a calcular de hecho el valor de re
cuadrada para esta recta qué tan buena
es el ajuste que tanto en la variación
total en los valores de que puede ser
explicada por la variación los valores
de x o por la recta en sí